neue leute es ist 20 46 und nicht viel
zu wenig geschlafen wir gestern noch
bestimmt war noch bis zum nächsten halt
zu erwachen oder so und dann könnte ich
jetzt heute nur bis halb sechs schlafen
so viele stunden ca die letzten acht
schon ziemlich kurz war aber heute ist
der große tag ich habe mich jetzt mal in
den keller unter geschlichen um diesen
wieder hier machen zu können ich werde
jetzt gleich noch die letzte dosis gehen
also letzten zwei spritzen nicht mehr
aufnehmen muss und dann kommt um halb
sieben ein taxi und das bringt mich
jetzt krankenhaus ich hoffe dass ich im
krankenhaus auch so ein bisschen film
kann ein stückchen zeigen kann wie
bisschen darf mich aussieht oder dann
wird das 45 stunden dauer nicht
angeschlossen bin als allererstes muss
hier irgendwie wach werden
wir sehen uns dann gleich wieder welchen
taxi bin
so wird jetzt da ist es immer noch
dunkle 57
ich werde jetzt gleich hier hoch gehen
rein gehen erstmal an da hochgehen mich
einweisen lassen und dann lass ich mich
anschließen und liegt an der fünf
stunden rum gucken ob ich drin aufführen
kann
jetzt sieht er hier das brett auf dem
ich lag ich hab das mal so stumm gefilmt
weil das bisschen seltsam weiter zu
kommentieren
ich war mit vier leuten in so einer
fläche rechts seht ihr noch einen auf
den wert von den wetten gab es dafür so
zwar auf der seite zwei hinter der
kamera die sz hier ist jetzt ein bild da
können wir genau darauf erkennen wie
diese gerätschaften der aussage dass
teil links von meinem bett was jetzt
gerade links mein bett ist die maschine
durch die man blut durch die in der das
zentrifugiert wurde der angriff agiert
und auf der rechten seite müsste das
müssen ein ekg maschinen automat gadget
teil sein
das halt mein puls bis hin geschickt hat
und er diese bauteile auf dem bett sind
ablagen für meinen abend der 45 stunden
dafür stunden auf dem rücken liegen
musste damit das funktioniert ja und
dann nach diesen nachdem die vier
stunden vergangen waren oder fünf
stunden war ich dann auch schon fertig
nachdem die maschinen abgestellt waren
habe ich mich dann noch eine stunde oder
zweieinhalb stunden noch im krankenhaus
aufgehalten hatte noch die gelegenheit
bisschen was zu essen bisschen was zu
trinken habe mich dann an diesem
wunderschönen tisch gesetzt und habe mir
da zeit um die ohren geschlagen
so leute das war's auch schon ich bin
jetzt wieder entlassen worden
ich lag da jetzt fünf stunden in dem
bett und habe mir das blut aus dem alle
namen raus laufen lassen durch die
maschine durch in den angaben wieder
rein
es war ich voll in ordnung die zeit
verging richtig schnell muss ich sagen
ich konnte kaum glauben dass die zeit
schon rum war so also fünf stunden
vergingen echt richtig schnell
was natürlich maßgeblich daran lag dass
da ein fernseher aber es hat natürlich
sehr so zum zeitvertreib beigetragen
danach habe ich dann auch eine
abstimmung gesetzt noch mal ein
ergebnisse gewartet und ich hab gehört
bei mir reicht dass ich es genug dabei
herumgekommen sozusagen ich muss morgen
nicht noch mal hin
das heißt das kapitel stammzellspende
ist für mich jetzt so weit abgeschlossen
von meiner seite aus zumindest
irgendwann in den nächsten wochen darf
ich dann endlich auch mal anrufen und
ein paar eckdaten zu meinem empfänger
erfahren
und ja ich muss sagen es war eine coole
sache abschließend so ich mache mich auf
den weg nach hause
ich bin ein bisschen müde ist denn
verpennt hat wenig geschlafen aber ich
muss alles sagen alles in allem war es
echt ne coole sache hat mich ein
bisschen schlafen aber also wenn man
vergleicht was ich jetzt aber einsetzen
müssen und was am ende bei rumkommen
kann man die heilung ist nicht
garantiert was dabei am ende bei
rumkommen kann für die person die krank
ist dann muss ich doch sagen es hat sich
gelohnt und ja wenn vielleicht eine auch
eine person da draußen jetzt durch diese
videos auch auf die idee kommt es auch
zu machen dann hat sie schon was
gebracht
ich würde sagen ich springe erstmal in
die straßenbahn nach hause weg und wir
sind dann wieder wenn ich zu hause bin
so leute und jetzt bin ich auch endlich
wieder zu hause
das heißt doch noch ewig gedauert das
hier zeigen dass weswegen ich jetzt noch
diese eine verabschiedung noch hier die
verbände so wie es bei mir aus sei hier
an dem verband hatte ich eine flexible
kanäle drin deswegen auch hier oben und
in der beuge weil der boj gekündigten
dynamik bewegen hier oben geht das dann
ist dieser und jährlich die die fixe
text falsch dann komplett text live die
waren halt so rein gesteckt so rein
können es sehen im video ja so und da
konnten arbeit nicht beugen
ich habe das nie erzählt letztendlich
richter alexander hold geschaut und so
aber es ging ja und dann dann ist jetzt
eigentlich auch schon soweit den wieder
zu beenden also ich hab vorher schon mal
gesagt aber alles in allem war es eine
sache die ich noch mal machen würde wenn
ich noch mal voll entscheidung stehen
würde und ja es ist eine spitzen immer
wasser sturm